c'est anxiogène c'est un univers
profondément que j'aime profondément
violent
[Musique]
aussi bien pour les policiers parce
qu'ils endurent des conditions de
travail qui sont dégradées qui sont
difficiles vous avez dans le même temps
ses vues des violences policières des
violences policières qui se font
toujours à l'encontre de personnes
noires d'origine arabe ou des migrants
ça c'est une réalité c'est ce que j'ai
pu observer mois dans le 19ème
arrondissement
je peux vous raconter mon premier jour
parce que c'est marquant une personne
qui en garde à vue qui demande à aller
aux toilettes
elle frappe une fois sur la porte pas de
réponse elle fera une deuxième fois sur
la porte toujours pas de réponse et
comme c'est urgent comme il faut
vraiment qu'elle allait aux toilettes
cette personne-là va frapper plus fort
sur la pente la troisième fois et là
qu'est ce qui se passe nous avons un
policier qui se lève qui va ouvrir la
porte de la cellule qui va le sortir ce
cette personne-là de sa cellule
l'emmener dans une autre pièce et le
frapper le comportement raciste et
violent ça reste le fait d'une minorité
de policiers
il n'y a pas de racisme systémique la
police en tout cas moi je n'ai pas
observé quand on est en patrouille dans
les rues du 19e les policiers quand ils
voient un groupe de jeunes gens nora
d'origine arabe ou des migrants en bas
d'un immeuble
lisa la des bâtards les bâtards c'est le
mot générique qui désigne des jeunes
hommes noirs d'origine arabe ou des
migrants et policiers les appelle comme
ça dans le 19e arrondissement il ya le
cas d'un d'un migrants marocains qui a
volé des piles et de la colle dans un
magasin de bricolage nous
on est appelés mais on se rend sur place
et notre simple boulot c'est de le
placer en garde à vue et en fait ça se
passe pas comme ça ça se passe pas comme
ça parce que un policier il se met à
l'arrière de la voiture à côté de ce
migrant marocain et le fera une hotte
abbas le policier ce jour-là il estime
que la justice française étant trop
laxiste ne condra ne va jamais condamné
ce migrants marocains là pour un simple
vol de piles et de et de colle donc est
ce qu'il fait il rend la justice lui
même et il le frappe et le tabasse il y
a quand même un train de formation j'en
parle dans le livre les policiers
contractuels ils sont formés trois mois
ces trois mois d'école seulement moi en
trois mois j'en suis sorti de l'école
avec une habilitation pour porter une
arme sur la voie publique j'avais jamais
touché une arme de ma vie avant j'étais
moi nul avec une arme j'étais un danger
public même avec une arme non m'a quand
même donné l'habilitation pour avoir
larmes et ensuite dans cette formation
là trois heures seulement sur les
violences conjugales et sur le terrain
les violences conjugales les violences
familiales
les différends entre voisins c'est la
majorité des interventions policières
les policiers ils viennent souvent de
milieux populaires ou de classes
moyennes en france et souvent de
province et la majorité des postes de
police massés à paris et en ile de
france
il ya vraiment un choc culturel entre
les policiers provinciaux de milieux
populaires les classes moyennes qui
arrivent ici la police fait face
aujourd'hui un problème de recrutement
la courbe elle fait ça donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe il faut quand même
continuer à envoyer des policiers
dans les commissariats et sur la rue
partout en france mais clairement h la
police fait face à un vrai prendre le
recrutement donc ils recrutent qu'ils
peuvent c'est ça la réalité
moi dans la chambre quand je suis en
école de police à saint malo en bretagne
il ya un homme qui est en cours de
formation pour devenir policier qui a un
casier judiciaire qui a déjà été
condamné pour des histoires de trafic de
drogue et c'est un autre qui était
proche de milieux néo nazis
il y avait même un journaliste dans
cette chambre
c'est pour vous dire à quel point la
police recrute qui elle peut